[Music]
I thoroughly and completely enjoyed this
film when you stop with your kids what
is your if kids think I loved it
yeah I've got a little more clout in the
house Gunther yeah okay here there
should be some gum or some candy in
there somewhere just help yourself don't
Rosita in the movie of course she's uh
she's got to be pretty regimented she's
gotta be pretty creative to keep things
move and keep things in line with the
kids as a mom do you have like any I
don't know mom hack that you use to keep
things like a daily regiment that helps
you keep things moving along I would say
if you're not yelling your kids not
spend enough time with them always clean
up clean up the dishwasher so sorry
how are you Matthew there's the youngest
one who you have to wake up very
differently than the other two it can be
a long process
he's young Livingston out of bed and
waking Greek today with that come at her
age yeah you're not allowed to speak
with them but you know you can't sit
close to him either
it gets me really mad well no not to
call me before 8:15 15 is when everybody
has to either be on a bus or at school
and then my whole life starts after 8:15